[Music]
excuse me coach Bella that'd be mean
George Cooper my daughter's here to try
out daughter well you didn't mention
that on the phone what I'll leave that
out well here she is
hi uh-huh you won't see her she can do I
want to see her go home
sorry come on I'm not gonna put a girl
on the team why not she's a girl she's
got pigtails Mischa give us a minute
no I want to hear look sweetheart I just
think it's great you want to be on the
team but these boys are gonna eat you
alive I'm not afraid of them
well maybe should be at least let her
throw a few she got a hell of an arm
George you're a football coach right mmm
you're gonna put a girl in your team
it's different it's contact sport
so is this she gets up to bat someone
deliberately throws a ball at her it's
gonna make contact
not even gonna give her a change
yeah come on let's get out of here
I'm sorry honey anyway don't send
Georgie to the store anymore to get you
beer he snitched on me well he tried to
steal one what happened you didn't make
the team she didn't even get to try out
why not
coach doesn't want a girl on his team
and you were okay with that no I tried
it was no change in his mind where are
you going somebody new are you alright
leave me alone
was there a written test and you
couldn't remember what I told you know
what you won't be on that baseball team
yes but the curse I don't care what he
said get your glove let's go okay Missy
what do good baseball yeah you tell my
granddaughter she can't play baseball oh
I'm just looking out for that's all is
that so yes ma'am it is well we don't
need you deciding what's best for her
huh
what do you need I need you to give her
the same chance you would a boy or what
are you and me gonna have problems well
we wouldn't want that would we no we
wouldn't
okay let's see what you got kid here you
tired in here baby
you scared me ma has just made a scene
now is not the time to be scared are we
gonna do this today keep your pants on
throw the damn ball I'm just a girl but
I think that's called a strike
[Music]
let it go she made the team
congratulations
and Memaw gonna date the coach what it
was a productive afternoon
[Music]